voilà c'est très récent il y a une
révélation dans public
c'est grâce à Bernard Montier
en fait
[Musique]
avec Adil Rami ah oui qui était venu ici
justement elle a craqué
il m'a appelé hier en plus parce que
j'étais avec lui avant-hier il m'a
appelé hier et il m'a dit je kiffe une
chroniqueuse et j'ai pensé à tout le
monde sauf à toi
et en plus je te jure il allait à
l'entraînement juste avant
l'entraînement il me dit je te rappelle
après l'entraînement c'est pas une balle
et et il m'a laissé un autre vocale il
m'a dit ouais frérot j'ai pas pu
t'appeler pour l'entraînement je te
rappelle aujourd'hui donc apparemment
c'est toi donc là
c'est pas moi qui le dit hein
comment ça se présente ben je pense
qu'il a envie de changer parce qu'il a
toujours eu quand même des filles très
très fort
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
il a envie autre chose je pense
est-ce que tu as déjà une aventure avec
quelqu'un de connu ben oui ça bien sûr
un humoriste mais très très ancien
[Applaudissements]
en même temps
[Musique]
j'étais la Camille quoi j'étais un
camion
parce que je voilà j'avais
18 ans
il avait que 55 un truc comme ça
[Musique]
il est il est là
55 ans
est-ce qu'il est mort dans les 10
dernières années bon allez je vous dis
oui c'est mon dernier indice
Google
les 10 dernières années
est-ce que sa femme l'a appris un moment
ou pas parce que franchement j'étais
tellement de choses
alors que la personne est déjà un jour
je peux vous le dire je le dire
qu'est-ce que tu attends en fait
il y avait plein de choses donc
en fait voilà je me reconnais pas de de
d'avoir fait ça mais c'était j'étais
jeune j'étais trop c'était trop une star
pour moi par semaine
des fois une fois seulement même des
fois avec lui
sans le dire parce que c'est une idée
sur l'avenir elle a dit qu'on le
connaissait peut-être même pas
c'est un mec drôle avec drôle ça peut
être un mec déjà deux qui se met tout nu
il est drôle
l'histoire donc au moins que j'ai un
petit peu un petit conseil
américain
tu prends bah écoute en tout cas c'est
sympa
vous Jean-Michel des histoires et des
stars j'en ai pas eu j'ai essayé avec
Eva Longoria enfin elle a essayé avec
moi
c'était
tu la connais ou pas je la connais ouais
non mais ici grâce à vous
donner son numéro enfin elle voulait mon
numéro elle devrait la retrouver le
lendemain matin au Bourget pour partir
avec elle
on l'avait piéger il est encore sur ce
piège je garde un spot que ce soit pas
pipeau
avec une quelqu'un de connu Kenza ah oui
c'est vrai que tu l'avais dit je la
kiffe en plus Kenza oui moi aussi et tu
es resté combien de temps non non pas
très longtemps c'est une amoureuse bah
lui il est sorti Kenzo du bois de
Boulogne
[Applaudissements]
je dis pécho une star apparemment
[Rires]
c'est comme Shy'm maintenant voilà
toi tu nous as dit oui toi tu nous dis
oui elle nous l'a dit oui
apparemment tu as visité pas mal de
doses
[Applaudissements]
jamais galoche
une bouche connue
qui était animatrice il y a quelques
années que vous connaissez
oui si Messi
[Rires]
supplémentaire
je t'explique c'est comme si tu dis je
cherche un animateur tu dis Nagui
voilà là le prénom que
[Applaudissements]
tu es mort tu es mort tu es mort elle
est belle elle est belle hein
alors moi il y a des acteurs qui ont
essayé des humoristes et des chanteurs
des footballeurs mais non mais voilà
mais moi je suis très difficile mon
numéro
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
dans la cuisine on passe par la fenêtre
s'il te plaît
au-delà de du fait que j'étais en couple
les temps où j'étais célibataire aussi à
ce moment-là et j'ai jamais ouvert la
porte et vous Gilles non je vous le dis
très modestement
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
attention attention mythomane
il va nous dire qu'il a
péchool je vais vous dire la vérité
lors d'une soirée à Cannes non Johnny
Depp était avec Kate Moss j'étais dans
la soirée
surprise et je vous le dis sincèrement
il s'est rien passé mais si elle avait
pas été avec lui je pense que vraiment
j'aurais eu ma chance
elle voulait partir avec Johnny en fait
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
il présentait ce brave à Cannes j'étais
à la soirée honnêtement ils étaient
assis tous les deux et moi je tournais
autour pendant très longtemps
[Rires]
et tout ça et ils étaient ensemble et
franchement
je t'ai pas demandé 2 minutes pourquoi 4
mots je te regardais parce que je crois
qu'elle me trouvait beau ouais et quand
elle a dit à Johnny Depp c'est qui ce
ouf
je t'ai pas demandé tu es pas posé la
question non vraiment oui et sinon
jamais personne non pareil avec Nicole
Kidman on a eu des regards aussi
j'ai une vie sentimentale un peu
tumultes
donc attendez attendez à 19h05 il y a
une meuf qui était Johnny Depp
elle a voulu quitter son Johnny Depp
pour Gilles et après attends après après
tu as tu as donc Nicole Kinder
qui a voulu quitter Tom Cruise pour Tom
shoes
[Applaudissements]
ça risque pas de m'arriver hein
0 galoche avec des stars
des stars jamais sauter la gueule
allez directement l'essentiel est-ce que
valangoria c'est comme votre sœur
c'est comme ma sœur mais vraiment je
l'adore alors je vais vous dire
tellement que je suis comme ça équival
je vous jure je l'adore quand elle était
là on rigolait je pourrais dormir nu
avec elle il se passera rien
que vous aviez vu le sexe de Raymond
parce que c'était un ami donc
c'est à la piscine il y avait pas la
perche pour faire nager les amis ben
voilà on a on a trouvé on a trouvé
donc la piscine bon les chéris